the grammar is something that we do care
about
but it's not something that should be
upfront hi steve kaufman here
today i want to talk about the
fifth of my
hierarchy of goals and and that's
grammar
some people may think that or at least
in traditional language instruction
grammar was the first goal get it right
but before i go any further remember if
you enjoy these videos
um
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
and um
if you follow me on a podcast service uh
please leave a comment we do appreciate
it
so i mean typically we're used to the
idea that
language instruction involves grammar it
involves the teacher explaining grammar
rules which are introduced one at a time
according to some
you know
order that someone decided we begin like
with the present tense and not the past
tense no real reason
typically in arabic they begin with the
past tense and then move to the present
tense
so there seems to be this order in which
grammar concepts are introduced and then
we're tested on them or we do exercises
on them and and the sort of the the core
element in language instruction seems to
be grammar everything is built around
grammar uh typically in these textbooks
there will be
you know content items items of content
to introduce new vocabulary but together
with that inevitably there is a concept
of grammar that is introduced
to me
grammar or speaking correctly or correct
usage
as a goal
is way down the list all right you by
now will know that i consider
acquiring words as the first goal
getting a lot of words
getting to where i can start reading in
the language is the second goal the
third goal is listening
and of course the the reading helps you
with the listening because if i just
hear it i don't necessarily know what
i'm listening to
and then i get to speaking because now
i've been listening to so much of the
language and i have words
i feel that i'm ready to speak
and so it's only when i start speaking
that my inaccuracy in the language
becomes a problem because as long as i'm
input-based i'm listening and reading
i'm acquiring words i can actually
understand fairly well what's happening
i have some concepts of the grammar but
because i'm not producing much of the
language i'm not making mistakes so it's
a happy situation i'm enjoying the
language no pressure no mistakes
now once i start speaking then of course
we all would like to speak more
correctly
more the usage patterns we want to
imitate the usage patterns of the native
speaker to some extent if we put a lot
of effort into our listening and reading
and we have lots of words we will have a
begin to have a feel for how the
language works
but
and we will notice certain patterns and
we will notice that for example the verb
comes at the end for example we don't
have to be told that that becomes pretty
obvious pretty quickly although if we're
told that up front there's nothing wrong
with that either but so much of of what
is in grammar at least in the initial
stages in my approach is just to be kind
of vaguely aware that these things is
exist in the language without
necessarily expecting to remember
anything
but comes a point now where i'm speaking
and i always make a struggle to get my
thoughts out and i'm not quite sure how
that structure works even though i've
seen it i'm not able to produce it and
so now we really have to focus in on
on producing the language correctly and
so but the advantage is if we start
focusing in on grammar
after having put enough effort into the
input
we now have some idea of what the
grammar explanations refer to because
we've already experienced much of it and
so we look at the grammar rule we still
can't apply it but i think that
studying grammar after a significant
exposure
to the language
helps us
grasp these grammar rules and even if we
forget them and we look at them again
and we look at them again and we look it
up again
slowly our ability to use the grammar
correctly improves and i don't think
it's necessary to be tested on them i
think it's enough to
review the grammar rules
try to notice them when we're listening
and reading
and i've always found that in time
if i have enough words i'll be able to
start speaking
so
the grammar is something that we do care
about
but it's not something that should be
upfront
and
because i'm very much focused on
input-based learning i i would like to
see more grammar
books
where
concepts of grammar are introduced
in the target language in spanish and
japanese and chinese
and that there is accompanying audio for
that lesson so that i can go away and i
can listen to a discussion of the
subjunctive in spanish with a lot of
examples
and i can listen to it and i can read it
so that it becomes a lesson like any
other lesson and i'm learning the
grammar rules but in the target language
i'm not sure if resources like that
exist
i've often
i haven't had that so what i've relied
upon is grammar resources that i can
find on the internet i can download a
pdf of romanian grammar i can look up
specifics of you know
ukrainian noun declensions or anything
really that you need to look up
you can look it up
and
certainly with verbs
at link we have conjugating dictionaries
in many cases so as you look up a form
of the verb it'll tell you which form it
is and it'll show you the other
you know conjugations of that verb so
there's so many resources around that
help us treat grammar as something that
we refer to
rather than something that has to be
deliberately learned and certainly not
deliberately learned up front
so
and with that i i find over time my
accuracy gets better
and but there will always be mistakes
and in many cases i'll make the same
mistake week after week month after
month and eventually these mistakes do
correct themselves
so
grammar therefore or correct usage is
for me
in my hierarchy of goals number five not
one not two not three not four but five
okay thank you for listening bye for now